this is a production of Cornell
University all right thanks much for the
introduction and thanks all of you for
coming here to see this presentation
unfortunately I don't have a nice
British accent like our speaker last
last week but I think it'll still be
hopefully interested in in what I have
to say especially because it has to do
with strawberries and I think most of
you are enjoying some strawberry
products right now so we can all
appreciate how to produce better
strawberries and more strawberries like
Marvin mentioned I'm doing soil health
and strawberry fields specifically soil
biological health and how how we manage
our so that field affects the biological
health indicators so I'm just going to
kind of go through my research the issue
that we saw and then show you some of my
results so the first thing I want to do
is define soil health usually when
people talk about soil health they like
to put this Venn diagram up and say that
soil health is at the intersection of
your chemical your physical and your
biological soil components and they say
soil health is right there in the middle
and that's true soil help does fall in
the middle of all these different soil
components however I don't think that
this diagram does a great job
distinguishing the difference between a
typical soil test and a soil health test
so for example pH which is a typical
soil test that we'd run you'd say that's
chemical however when you think about it
the plants that grow in that soil and
the microbes that live in that soil
affect the pH and likewise the pH of
that soil affects the plants and the
microbes that can grow in that soil so
really pH is somewhere in this gray area
here and it for another example
aggregation that's okay we'd say that's
a physical component of your soil but
then aggregation is helped by bacteria
usage l's and fungal mycelium that help
hold the our gets together so really
aggregation is also in this gray
area here so my idea is that while soil
health does fall the intersection of
these three most soil soil tests fall
somewhere there so to really explain
soil health I prefer to use the
definition that was created by the soil
science society of america at their
committee on soil quality so they define
soil health as the capacity of a
specific kind of soil to function within
both managed and natural ecosystems to
sustain plant and animal productivity
and we want to maintain an or enhance
water and air quality and support human
habitation so there's kind of a lot in
that definition and it might be hard to
visualize just reading all of those
words so if I were to make a Venn
diagram of soil health it would be more
like this I'd say that first and
foremost we have to define what our soil
function is so are we growing something
on these strawberries are on the on the
soil or do we want to support a park or
do we want to build a building what is
the function of that soil and then once
you define that function we want it to
have ecosystem sustainability and we
want it to maintain our air and water
quality and then because we're a little
bit egocentric we needed to support
humans if it doesn't support us we're
not going to manage that soil that way
for very long so it's a critical
component of a healthy soil and at that
intersection there which is a little bit
maybe smaller of an overlap that's where
we we have a really healthy soil you
might notice that most of these all four
of these are somewhat defined components
of soil we and we get to define them
from so we get to say what the soil
function is and we get to say how it
supporting humans which makes a lot of
people a little bit a lot of scientists
a little bit nervous about it because
that means that since we're defining
them that
these definitions can shift with time
and political and social movements so
for example air and water quality right
now climate change and problem in the
future climate change will also be a big
issue so we're concerned about carbon
dioxide emissions but a while back and
who knows what will happen in the future
carbon dioxide emissions weren't really
what we're concerned about so today
carbon dioxide emissions might be part
of a healthy soil but in the future
maybe in the past they weren't so you
can see that we kind of get to put
emphasis on what we want so the help
healthy soil definition kind of shift so
it can be a little difficult in our case
we're looking at healthy soil in a
strawberry field so that soil function
that we've defined is to produce
strawberries and then that ecosystem
sustainability what we want it to do is
to provide a good habitat for soil
microbes and hopefully that can help us
reduce external inputs to the system
because we won't have to add fertilizers
as often or external fertilizers if the
soil microbial community can do a good
job of cycling nutrients back through
the soil we also hope that it the good
soil microbial community will cut back
on disease incidence and we won't have
to put as many pesticides on the field
we still want this soil to maintain air
and water quality and we need it to be
profitable it's not profitable a grower
can't continue to grow strawberries that
way so that's kind of our soil health
goal that's what we want our soil to do
unfortunately there's no way to just
measure all four of those bullet points
if with one test there's no this is a
soil health test so what we do is we
define our goal and then we have to come
up with the desired soil functions that
will get us to that goal so for example
a desired soil function that we might
have would be to increase that soil
microbial community then we choose
indicators that measure that soil
desired function so indicators that
might measure soil microbial community
could be respiration or chloroform
fumigation and then we run that
indicator test and we get a value from
that so let's say we run a respiration
test and we get a value of you know 10
milliliters okay what does that mean
that that's that's meaningless until we
value it so then we put that indicator
value onto through a scoring function
and we score it based on whether we want
more of that more of that indicator
whether we want less of that indicator
or whether we want that indicator to
fall within a specific range and once it
has a score we can combine all the
scores of all the indicators that we
test that we've run and we get a final
soil quality score so there's no way to
jump directly from here to here but we
can break this out kind of tease it
apart and then hopefully combine it back
together to get our soil quality score
and hopefully we've chosen our
indicators appropriately so that they're
they accurately give a soil quality
score that represents the soil in our
field so it can be a little bit
difficult making sure that we've
selected all these correct indicators
and and that our soil quality score
relates back to this soil health goal
when we're choosing soil health
indicators there are a couple different
parameters first and foremost they have
to accurately target that soil function
that we're interested in because if
they're not different about targeting
that that function then then it's and
it's somewhat meaningless but they also
have to be quick to respond to
management practices because if we
change our management practice but the
indicator test doesn't respond we could
be degrading our soil for many years
before we realize that we have to go
back and make some changes it's also
important for them to be inexpensive
reliable and fast so that could be
tricky and I think that as soil health
tests become more and more popular that
people will learn which indicators are
more useful
back in 2008 Cornell created their own
soil health training manual and it's
available to growers and like I
mentioned they had to choose indicators
and they are upgrading their indicator
so that they're more applicable to a
healthy soil when I started it's the
indicators that were in a soil health
tests are different from the indicators
that are there now and if we look at
their test score card that they give you
if you get a cornell soil health test we
can see that it kind of follows that
flow chart that I showed you a couple
slides ago so here we've got our
chemical or biological and our physical
components of our soil and those would
be the desired soil functions that they
want the soil to complete and then
they've chosen indicators here that
indicate those three different functions
so for example one of the biological
functions we want our soil to function
well biologically so they've said
percent organic matter is an indicator
of how well your soil will function
biologically and then they write on that
test and they got a value of 2.6 that
value of 2.6 we don't really know what
that means yet until we run it through a
scoring function and and we score based
on whether we want more less or specific
range so they wanted more of percent
organic matter and since 2.6 is somewhat
low they only gave it a rating so a
score of 25 and their rating scale goes
from 1 to 100 1 being the least
desirable and 100 being the most
desirable so you can see here we have a
100 for pho 104 extractable phosphorus
but go all the way down to 94
potentially mineralized vil nitrogen so
they score those each indicator and then
they combine them to an overall soil
quality score this soil got a score of
64 and
so that's kind of how it looks in
reality but the Cornell soil health test
was developed mostly mainly on grain and
vegetable crops but my advisor Marvin
wanted to try and make it more
applicable to Barry growers since we
want to encourage bear growers to also
have healthy soil and if any of you are
interested this is a yellow collar
that's being developed in Geneva so we
can be proud of our beautiful collards
when Marvin gave Cornell soil health
test to Barry growers across upstate New
York trying to make sure that this test
was applicable to Barry growers and get
them excited about it we looked at the
strawberry grower data on its own and
noticed that the biological soil health
indicators from those tests all came
back very low so you can see these are
the biological indicators that we looked
at organic matter active carbon
potentially mineralized while nitrogen
and we can see that their indicator
ratings on that scale from 1 to 100 are
all kind of below 30 so they had pretty
low soil biological health and we were a
little bit confused by this because
strawberry growers add a lot of organic
matter to their fields through straw
what they'll do is they'll put straw in
their fields in the fall and when you
when you pile straw pit traps a lot of
air and acts as a really great insulator
for for the plants so they'll put the
straw on in the winter and if they've
piled enough on there you can see that
they have nice undamaged flowers in the
spring however if they don't put enough
on or they don't insulate their their
plants they can get cold damage
especially in the early spring like we
see here with this black flower so they
they put them on in the fall they let
them over winter and then in the spring
the growers will come and they'll rake
the straw between the rows and then the
straw that was once an insulator then
becomes a mulch and this mulch layer is
really
Martin because it keeps it keeps the
berries up off the dirt off the soil the
soil carries a lot of very diseases and
if the soil can't reach the berry then
it doesn't get those diseases so it's a
really important layer between between
the soil and the berry it also keeps the
berries clean and that's important
because the strawberry grower can't wash
their berries before they ship their
berries if they were to wash their
berries before shipping them by the time
it reached the consumer the berries
would be rotted but on the other hand no
consumer is going to want to buy dirty
berries so having those clean berries
where the soil can't bounce up on onto
them from the rain is really important
so we're adding a lot of organic matter
to these systems nonetheless we have low
soil biological health it was a little
bit confusing however we know that straw
has a really high carbon to nitrogen
ratio and it's been shown in other
studies that carbon nitrogen radio ratio
especially when high can have a negative
effect on soil biological health this is
a graph from a different experiment but
if we just focus on two lines here we've
got broccoli residue in the solid black
line and this dotted line is broccoli
residue plus wheat straw so broccoli
residue on its own has a very low carbon
to nitrogen ratio but broccoli residue
plus wheat straw has a much higher
carbon to nitrogen ratio and then on
this y-axis here we have net nitrogen
mineralization and you can see that the
zero no nitrogen mineralization is right
is right here so if we have that low
carbon to nitrogen ratio amendment the
broccoli we can see that we're having
positive net nitrogen mineralization so
if we put on that higher carbon nitrogen
amendment where we add in the wheat
straw we can see that we actually have
negative nitrogen mineralization meaning
that we're having nitrogen
immobilization and so that's indicating
that there's poor biological soil health
it's not it's not the goal that we want
we want more
generateur soil not less so we were
thinking that the high carbon to
nitrogen ratio of straw was possibly
having a negative effect on the plants
or on the soil health oops strawberry
growers also typically use cultivation
to deal with their weeds a lot of
herbicides target broadleaf perennial
plants and unfortunately strawberries
are also broadleaf perennial plants so
instead of using her besides they often
will just cultivate until their soil but
there have been a lot of studies showing
that cultivation can have a negative
impact on soil biology so here we're
looking again at a study from somebody
else but the two treatments to your left
are no-till treatments and the two
treatments to your right these are
conventionally tilled treatments and I
just want to point out that the no-till
treatments have a lot more fungal hyphae
than the conventionally tilled
treatments so you can just see that
tilling can decrease soil biological
life and therefore we thought maybe that
the high intensity of tilling at
Strawberry Fields was also having a
negative effect so what we did is we
designed an experiment out here in East
Ithaca where we put on four different
well we had four different soil
amendment treatments along a carbon to
nitrogen ratio scale so you can see
sawdust had a very high carbon to
nitrogen ratio and then straw was
somewhere in the middle and then grass
at a very low carbon to nitrogen ratio
and we and then we also had an unmanned
'add control we put those amendments on
the soil in fall of 2013 and then we
tilled them into the soil and then in
the spring of 2014 we planted honey why
strawberries on that field I want to
make it clear that this is not what a
grower would do a grower would just
simply plant their strawberries directly
into the field
spring and then apply that straw it for
winter protection in the late fall early
summer and then would rake that straw
into the rose in the next spring and
then as they tilled that would
eventually become a soil amendment but
we wanted since I'm only going to be
here for two and a half years we wanted
to get a little bit of a jump start so
we applied the amendments to the soil
right away to try to see if we could
make differences in our soil health
indicators more quickly and then we this
is this is your he was department here
at the time so what a typical department
chair does are you ready Steve to do
that but um anyway so we had two
different tillage treatments as well we
tilled half of our plots as shallow as
possible and then we tilled half of our
plots about a foot deep here you can see
us tilling with the what is it the
Reggie wieder leader rotary cultivator
so yeah this is a picture of our plot
map and you can see the four different
soil amendments that we added are
indicated by the different colors we've
got unda mended treatments in blue we've
got graphs amended treatments and green
straw amended treatments in that brown
color and then sawdust a minute
treatments in purple and then we hatched
the plots that are that or deep tilled
and then the ones that aren't hatched
are shallow tilled treatments
I wanted to give you a quick timeline of
what we did so that just to make sure
everyone's on the same page again we
applied these we applied the soil
amendments in the fall of 2013 and then
we let them over winter we didn't take
the first soil sample until the next May
and then we planted our strawberries
actually after our first soil sample and
then we took our second and third soil
samples and again applied more
amendments in the fall of 2014 we let
those over winter and then in May again
we took a for soil sample harvested the
berries in June of 2015 and then took
our fifth soil sample in August we
didn't want to confound our amendment
study by putting straw on for winter
protection so instead of using straw we
used row cover so you can see that here
to let him make sure that you know that
we didn't use straw even though growers
often do they can also use row cover and
then every time we took a soil sample we
looked at five different soil parameters
we did a soil respiration test we did a
potentially min risible nitrogen test a
carbon to nitrogen ratio test pH and
soil moisture
and then before I start talking about
data there's one more thing that I want
to explain so we weren't sure if we
should sample between the rows where we
were actually applying the amendments
and we were actually you know
cultivating or if we should sample
within the rows where the strawberries
were actually growing so we weren't we
weren't sure which would be have a
greater effect on the soil health
parameters so what we did is we sampled
in both and kept them separate so that's
why when you look at these tables you
see an amendment treatment and then a
tillage depth treatment and then you see
a sample location treatment and we
didn't have a sample location treatment
this first sample date because we didn't
have any strawberries so there weren't
any rows to sample between Earth in so
we just sampled that date and then for
all the rest of the dates there's
there's this additional sample location
treatment which indicates whether we
sampled between the rows are within the
roast and so here we're looking at our
respiration data you can see the five
different sample dates all the way to
the left and then we've got into not
significant data is indicated all the
way to the right here with an NS and
then these are these are p values that
we've showed you that are that are
significant and you can see that
amendment often has a significant effect
on soil respiration but tillage step
does not we also see a slight
interaction effect between the amendment
and the sample location here on the
second date so what does that mean we
take a look at the graph here you can
see our on our y-axis we've got the
milliliters of co2 respired and then
down here on the x-axis we've got each
sample date and then the first sample
date we only have between data because
we didn't have rows and then every other
sample date we have both between and
within and within is kind of a little
bit grayer if that helps you see this
graph a little bit better and we've got
our four different soil amendments
unamended grass straw and sawdust so we
noticed that sawdust often had higher
respiration than any of the other
treatments but if you remember from that
chart the second sample date had an
interaction effect between the soil
amendment and the sample location so we
can see that within straw had the
highest respiration but between the rows
straw and sawdust had actually the same
respiration so that's where we get that
interaction effect coming into play so
we thought this was really interesting
but we were a little concerned because
we're adding sawdust and sawdust has a
really high carbon to nitrogen ratio so
we're adding an amendment with a lot of
carbon so you'd think well obviously we
can get more carbon dioxide if we're
adding more carbon to the system so
we've decided we were going to try to
fix that and we changed our y-axis from
total milliliters of carbon dioxide
emitted to grams of carbon respired per
gram of carbon in the soil because we
had measured the carbon in the soil as
well for each sample so it is the same
chart but with a different y-axis and we
can see that the the graph looks pretty
much the same usually we still have
highest the highest respiration in our
saudis amended soil except on this
second sample date straw has higher
respiration both both between and within
the rose so that was kind of interesting
then we took a look at our potentially
mineralize abul nitrogen data and we can
see that once again until its def had no
significant effect on any of our on
potentially mineralized able nitrogen
but amendment did but it mostly had an
effect in the two springs and then a
slight a slight amendment and sample
location interaction effect in the
summer of 2015 so if we look at that
graphically again that first sample date
it's interesting we see pi potentially
mineralized able again in the straw the
sawdust amended treatment so that kind
of lined up with our respiration data
and I was I was interesting but then the
second spring we didn't see that same
that's that same line up so we can see
that sawdust does have high respiration
but it is tied with the grass and the
straw amended soil and then I like I
mentioned we had that slight interaction
effect on the final sample date so you
can see that between and within had
slightly different responses for
potentially mineralize about nitrogen
and if we now look at our carbon and
nitrogen data there is no real
significant interact effect of any of
our treatments on carbon and nitrogen
ratio so the reason this is really
interesting is because even though we
were adding soil amendments with vastly
different carbon and nitrogen ratios to
our soil it wasn't coming through in the
soil itself so in if we had continued
this study for many years or if we had
added vastly more of our soil amendment
we might expect to see that carbon to
nitrogen ratio differ between the
treatments but apparently the amount
that we added for the time that we added
it there was no difference in that ratio
this is also really interesting because
remember if you remember back to
respiration we changed our respiration y
axis from total milliliters of carbon
dioxide to grams of carbon emitted
through a respiration per gram of carbon
in the soil and we can see that there
was no real difference between our
different soil treatments in the carbon
in the amount of carbon and nitrogen
that was in the soil so even though we
made that conversion since we didn't see
differences in carbon and nitrogen ratio
data we didn't really see any
differences in those two graphs when we
change the y axis so that might be part
of the reason why the respiration looked
the same depending looked at it when we
looked at ph there were no differences
in pH based on any of the treatments
that we applied however we when we we
looked between the rows and within the
rose we could see differences so at
first the well this this sample date
here they were the same however after
that within the Rose had lower pH then
between the rows and this makes sense
because when we fertilized we used urea
and we did we did banded fertilization
we didn't broadcast the fertilizer we
just put it right next to the plants so
and and urea can slightly acidify your
soil and I think we're seeing part of
that effect here also in plants up
taking nutrients are emitting they can
emit some acidic compounds and slightly
acidify the soil and I think the
combination of those two is the reason
why we're seeing more acidic soil in
between there within the rows then
between thought that was kind of cool
the seat so we'll moisture again we look
and we don't really see any pattern of
differences based on our different
treatments there are some significant
effects but it was not consistent so we
can't really say say much about soil
moisture we think this might just have
to do to the fact that slow moisture is
pretty variable it can change from day
to day and from location to location
depending upon what the soil what it's
covered with and and who's drawing
moisture out of that soil so we didn't
really see much of interest with soil
moisture so the first question that we
really wanted to answer was do soil
amendments and tillage depth have an
effect on soil biological health
indicators and what we can say yes and
no yes amendment had an effect on
respiration and potentially mineralized
well nitrogen but tillage duck didn't
really have an effect on any of our soil
health indicators
but we also wanted to look at yield and
if you guys remember back to the
timeline that i showed the yield we only
took we only harvested the berries once
so we only have one set of yield data
just to keep that in the back of your
mind but we here you can see our
amendment and our depth treatments and
we tried to see if there was an effect
on the marketable yield and the plant
the plant density and you can see that
there is both an effect of amendment on
marketable yield and plant density so if
we come down here and we look at our
marketable yield straw had a
significantly lower yield than any of
the other amendments that we added to
our soil as well as it had significantly
lower plant density than the other
amendments that we added to the soil
this was surprising because well first
of all it's not along that carbon to
nitrogen ratio scale that we had at
first thought was going to be the issue
we thought that if straw had lower
yields that sawdust would have even
lower yield but that didn't seem to be
the case and straws also what growers
typically use so they might not realize
that the they're not producing
strawberries to the fullest potential
yield that they could get we calculated
it and it would was about a twenty
percent decrease in Los and profits and
yield so that's pretty significant you
could you could even see it out in the
field I know this is not the best
picture but if you look here this is a
straw amended plot as well as here here
there that's them right over in that
corner there and it's really hard to see
the plants in those plots that's why
they're kind of easy to pick out and
it's true that the straw is kind of
mounded up and that may be one reason
why you can't see the plant the plants
very well in this pitcher but also the
plants were very short and small and and
and that's another reason why you can't
see the plants so well miss pitcher and
the straw amended plots
if you look at it this way it might be a
little easier to see in the middle we
have our straw amended soil on the
bottom we have our unamended soil and
then on the top we have our sawdust
amended soil and all these plants were
planted on the same day and the same
distance apart and it's pretty visually
clear that the straw amended soil
produced smaller plants or they grew
slower than the rest of the unamended
and the sawdust amended treatments as
well as the grass but graphs we expected
to have good growth because it had a lot
of nitrogen but we didn't expect straw
to actually decrease growth which it
seemed to do because our unamended soil
had had better growth than than the
straw metod soil I know yeah and that's
even one of the reasons that's one of
the hypotheses of why we named
strawberries strawberries because we
grow them in straw so what are we going
to do I don't know if we're gonna have
to rename them or yeah wheat yeah we'd
straw yes sorry
yeah so so good question well I'm going
to get to that question in two slides is
that ok ok so uh the first thing I
wanted to point out is that even though
we saw these decreased yields and we saw
the decreased density we are not going
to recommend to growers currently that
they should stop using straw because if
you remember the beginning straw has a
lot of benefits it insulates the berries
and then it provides that nice thick
mulch layer between the soil and the
berry and that not only decreases
diseases it also keeps the berries clean
so here on our y-axis now this is a good
thing we have grams of unmarketable
strawberries and you can see that our
unmarketable strawberries in the straw
minutes well we're much lower so if I
have shown you total yield data that
when I two slides ago or think three
sides ago the the differences between
the straw and the sawdust and the grass
amount of treatments would have been
much greater but you can see how much
straw decreased disease so it still has
a lot of benefits you can also see it
keeping the strawberry up off the soil
you can't see the soil in this picture
because you know there's a nice thick
layer and that's really important for
Barry growers before they ship for when
they ship their berries now we don't
think that it's okay to have reduced
yields so we tried this past winter to
figure out what it was that was
decreasing yield what mechanism in the
straw was actually causing this
decreased yield we came up with a couple
different ideas the first being just
like James pointed out we thought maybe
it's a chemical leak Jake because wheat
straw has been shown to have leelah
pathak effects on other plans we also
were thinking maybe it was some kind of
microbial community maybe the straw was
encouraging a microbial community to
grow there that that was actually
detrimental to strawberry plant growth
we thought that maybe there was like a
physical barrier like when the when the
strawberry plants were sending out their
daughter plants their runners and then
the daughter plants are trying to send
down those roots that the roots couldn't
make it out to the soil quick enough and
that was decreasing growth or we thought
maybe there was some kind of herbicide
residue left over on that straw that was
then affecting those strawberry plants
because like we mentioned strawberry
plants are broadly perennial as our most
herbicide as do most herbicide target so
we tried all these things in the
greenhouse but unfortunately we weren't
actually able to recreate the negative
growth that we saw in the field in the
greenhouse which was a little bit
disappointing because we would really
hope that we'd be able to answer that
question like what is it in the straw
that's that's causing a reduced growth
but the greenhouse environment and the
outdoor environment are very different
and so you know it's possible that there
was just some key element out in the
field that we didn't recreate in the
greenhouse that was that was what would
have made us been able to answer this
question but it's really interesting and
someone hopefully will answer it so do
treatments affect yield again we can say
yes and no amendments do affect yield
straw can decrease yield but a tillage
didn't have much of an effect or I
didn't have any effect the last thing we
tried to do is you try to correlate our
soil health parameters with yield so you
can see here all the way to the left we
have marketable yield and along the top
we have our five different soil health
parameters and we were hoping that some
of them would be highly correlated but
we didn't really see any pattern so we
don't have anything to say about how
soil health can directly affect yield at
this time that being so so our soil
health indicators correlated with yield
we haven't been able to show that yet
that being said that doesn't yield falls
under this human support and and that
soil functionality it doesn't really
fall under ecosystem sustainability or
helping to maintain air and water
quality so we can still be increasing
our soil health overall but not
increasing yield and this is important
because you know we planted strawberries
in a soil that hadn't had strawberries
planted in it for many years it was
pretty pretty good soil and all of our
plants overall group grew very well so
there wasn't a lot of
eases built up in the soil there weren't
a lot of pests strawberry specific pests
living in the area so our system wasn't
very stressed and it'd be really
interesting to see what happened when
the system did become stressed that's
when a healthy soil might really help
increase yield or keep yields high where
an unhealthy soil would kind of drop off
so we think that maybe with time these
effects might might become more clear I
just wanted to quickly go over like kind
of highlight what we what we found in
the study because there's kind of a lot
it was a little bit all over the board
so to reiterate soil amendments do
affect soil health indicators but not
based on that carbon to nitrogen ratio
scale like we originally thought if they
had then sawdust would have had the
highest respiration and the highest pmn
and then grassman it so I would have had
the lowest but that's not that's not
what we always saw um tilling did not
affect the soil health indicators in our
study however was only a two year study
and most chilling experiments are long
term so we're thinking that but we were
hoping that the soil health parameters
would react so quickly to these
management practices that they would
kind of let us give us a heads up that
it was maybe degrading our soil
biological health but it didn't appear
to do that in the long term it would be
interesting to see what what happens we
saw that pH was higher between the rows
than it was within the rows which was
interesting and soil amendments do
affect yield but again not based on that
carbon to nitrogen ratio of scale so
sawdust or straw had the lowest yield
but thought us did not have even lower
grass did not have even higher yield so
again tilling did not affect yield but
like we mentioned this is only a two
year study and most chilling experiments
are long-term be interesting to see what
happens in the long term we were unable
to find a link between soil health and
yield but over time when when more
stressors enter the environment we might
be able to find the correlation and even
though straw decreased strawberry growth
and yield we were unable to figure out
exactly what it was about the straw that
was decreasing growth and so we're not
going to recommend that growers stop
using straw all together yet maybe if
they want to try using a little less
straw in certain parts of their field
although they have to make sure they put
enough on there to adequately insulate
or if they want to try using some straw
and another amendment in conjunction
with a straw maybe that would be good
but until we know we can't really say
what it is that you need to change to
get your yield back up to its full
potential and quickly before I finish I
just wanted to thank everyone who helped
make this research possible because I
certainly couldn't have done on my own
first and foremost I want to thank
Marvin who's my advisor and then
everyone who works with him both Casper
and kathy was a huge part of this
research and she's greatly missed I also
need to really thank you hon us in his
lab because he let me use his lab space
and with his lab space come Kelly and
Akio who are his technicians who also
really help whenever you have a soil
question I used some lab space in the
Cornell nutrient analysis laboratory and
Tim dodge really helped to keep those
strawberries live when they need to be
watered I couldn't have done it without
funding from both the hatch and
horticulture department and thank you
graduate students and the six
departments but mostly horticulture and
also my family and I think we have some
time for questions but not too much so
yeah thank you was that for that field
so can you tell us what the measurements
like soil organic net or whatever he did
me you know the diverse test yeah so
their success resent yeah so the first
test was just to kind of show you what
the Cornell so I helped lab does but we
didn't use the Cornell so a health ought
to do our test was when we were really
interested in doing a respiration test
and at the time they didn't include that
but now they do so we've kind of chose
our own soil help foreigners that's why
we did CNN ratio respiration pmn we
don't have those specific tests would
have been so
yeah two questions Maria first is how
much straw or sawdust or grass did you
apply yeah so we use the amount that a
strawberries or we take typically apply
which I think was like two times and
make 308 an acre to insulate and then we
drive that waited and then we added an
equivalent mass basis first sawdust and
grasp okay second question is on the I
marketable yield oil treatment had lower
our market bought you but on percentage
basis would that be the same or store
lower um I don't think I ran that but I
I don't think it
okay seemed like a good idea to express
the data on a percentage basis okay
thanks for the feedback
yeah well what threshold were you using
for the market will vary yeah so that
was interesting at the time you were
like well you can market a very that you
can't Martin a very them as disease this
summer we had a lot of disease so
because remember if you remember June it
rained like almost every day I maybe
every other day so anything that was
rotten we said that was unmarketable we
also never lost looks 20 times worse
flood damage that was not okay Barry was
broken in any way from someone stepping
on it or gonna cracked that was not okay
but at the time we were like oh if it's
dirty that's probably ok but but I don't
think so we included dirty very in our
marketable deal hope you probably
shouldn't have because in reality I'll
go to bury is intact and it's fine that
doesn't have
the doesn't doesn't you know the cut it
probably would be hard for a grower to
market it they have to wash it and then
sell immediately or you have to market
envy you pick people who or okay berries
that then they go take home and wash the
very firm idea being that they weren't
really good for awakeness grass used is
mulch or as organic matter yeah so we so
on that first fall in 2013 he
incorporated that right into the soil to
kind of get a job start so that was more
of an amendment and then the next fall
instead of killing those amendments it
would just left them on the surface of
the soil trying to kind of emulate what
our strawberry girl would do because
they wouldn't amend them and are they
going to tilt him into the soil until
the next spring when they needed to week
so we did that we just left them on a
soil surface and then the next spring
when we needed to leave that's when we
use that's when it kind of came from a
mulch into an amendment
your throw is used
yeah but they don't produce them quite
the same way than they do in California
it's a little bit of a different system
but they do use black basketball so
that's an important option sometimes
they still use strong meeting the Rose
because it's also nice just for it you
have
yep our star peepers
sorry
how long how often they are
so they'll replace their strawberry
plants maybe after three or four years
that's when it kind of doesn't become it
when it's not economical anymore to keep
them because every time they produce
very still produce a little bit smaller
or a little less than next year um the
recommendation is that they rotate after
that three or four years but in reality
that doesn't always happen a lot of
times they do keep their their fields
the same spot just like to grow their
business one spot so some do they
probably should some don't
it possible that this child is keeping a
slight temperature a little bit
bothering action
I guess in that in the green yeah I mean
that exact so yeah Strom was most likely
to be the temperature lower we didn't
measure soil temperature but from other
literature that I've got it usually does
the soil temperature lower and then in
the greenhouse yeah it was temperature
was regulated so we really have those
pots we're sitting up high so it has
something to do with temperature also in
the greenhouse community we worked hard
too we got like longer deeper pots and
tried to plant the strawberries a little
lower without them being too low into
the pot and then piling the mulch on top
but we probably didn't get the same
amount of mulch that we got we were able
to get a feel for you really I don't
wanna which occur does so it might also
have to do with your mouth straw
yeah so her vegetables and rear crops
they're really pushing this Cornell soil
health test for orchard systems and
vineyard systems we've had a hard time
really showing that that suite of tests
really you know tells us very much about
soil health so for strawberries
strawberry growers should they be using
the soil test and if not is there a
modification that you would think would
be useful to add to the Cornell test and
make it useful for server herbs yeah so
that was kind of what like originally
motivated distance that okay you know
should this be use for their doors can
be get them excited about doesn't even
need anything and that's why we were
really hoping at the end to correlate so
he sweat off members and deal i would
say that there are probably benefits to
soil hometown when we when we gave the
sweat health test to all those berry
growers their their chemical and their
physical soil parameters all came back
you know me the greens few yellows mixed
in there so they were they were all fine
it was when you went to the biological
components that's when we got we saw red
we saw them really low
value scorp like scores so I think that
a grower sees their chemical and their
physical components on a regular basis
when they take their swell test and they
they see that initially can manage or
soil for that fourth floor of those
components but they never test the
biological on it so they can't see how
they're doing and to be honest I think
that soil health is is something that is
still somewhat new and maybe not within
the science community but when you're
trying to translate it from talking
about it and developing its test to
actually implementing that test as a
grower in the field and so I think that
there's going to be a lot of
modifications that will have to be made
to the soil tests that are available and
I don't know the best the best
indicators because selecting those
interviews just really critical but I
think there's a lot of a lot of
developments being made especially in
soil microbiology I think that hopefully
those will trickle down and those kind
of testing become less expensive and
or indicative of how the soil violent
the community kind of really is looking
right now we're just doing is our
lotteries are little that's really crew
you'd be better if you can do what is
there is an antagonistic as a
protagonist stick so I think that those
will get better with time but right now
we need we need the data to be able to
make that better so we want people to
get on board but i think that when we
look back in 50 years like all those
tests weren't very good but we need to
start somewhere Thanks this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu